[Music]
everybody welcome back to koala beach
were already on episode 29 and today I'm
tackling an area made by Rudy and it's
actually it's one of my favorite builds
in the park so far it's very
revolutionary it's the first built that
we're getting into the new update which
while his built was the first built that
we're getting into the new update of the
game which means that we can add screens
with our own textures and things and as
you can see he's added all kinds of
revolutionary things with that given an
aquarium and lagoon with a custom
texture and we've also got a mine train
now the one thing that he did leave me
to work on is the station for the mine
train that's what we're going to work on
in this episode and we'll try to catch
up a little bit about what really has
made it well but first and foremost I
need to enter them introduce the man the
legend himself ladies and gentlemen his
good evening canal oh boy what you said
okay
may I take your budget amazing
introduction yeah how are you doing so
I'm pretty fine actually actually this
is not so fine I had to pull this thing
out of out of somewhere very last minute
because unfortunately you might have
noticed that lady isn't here at the
moment she's going through some private
problems so unfortunately she can't be
there and she also can't record so very
last minute I've been given the profile
and I needed to do something with it
so here you have is with all this kind
of book together in a hurry but that
said I absolutely love the stuff that
you've been doing in the profile
obviously you really you really seem
like you've been on a roll over here
recently yeah I was definitely and
thanks I'm really happy to say that they
like it
um because I I was afraid to see what
you guys say because I yeah you just
noticed it correctly I was kind of in
rush in a positive one because like the
when the billboards were announced I was
like having a million
I do connect I guess I even wrote you
some already in before and here you also
might know in this video is about yeah
and I was like really excited about it
already so I had this in my idea in mind
for quite a long time and once I had the
file again I I just needed to go in and
that said we had an episode of 45 this I
guess well a little bit most real time
that I even lost like two hours of
footage so that was kind of you know
really in a Russian and really happy
that it sounded great and regards liked
it so I must say I'm super happy used to
just second the station and before
anyone else is going to mention that in
a comment for you I have to tell it it's
totally fine that you're tackling the
mind train on this point with the
station because I also tried to mention
the last time already I didn't even pay
attention to the station at all because
I lost so much footage and I didn't want
to do you know even one more thing after
the entire lagoon with all these little
aquariums and I thought it was just
enough on an episode so yeah there you
go
I'm so sorry you just had to pop it in
now in your free time so quickly so I
just hope you read next a little bit
beforehand on your holiday yeah I
actually do yeah I just came back for my
holidays and then I got this thing to
work week so that was kind of right but
no we actually extended my personal
deadline by one day because I ended up
spending a lot of time with the screens
because quite honestly this was also my
catch-up time with planet coaster I
hadn't played it for a while a while
being like two weeks maybe but that
feels like a long time but it's I I did
I haven't played it since the update
basically and I haven't really messed
around with the screen so this was my
time getting used to it and especially
after seeing Rudy being basically the
pioneer in doing all kinds of different
things with these Queens I wasn't really
too sure what to do with them but in the
end and this is probably an interesting
topic for the rest of this video I'm
kind of skeptical about it it's
something which I'm not entirely sure if
it's something that I really like but
that said I was kind of on a roll with
this video as well I quite liked working
on the station
I'm very far from being done actually by
the end I just go madly into detailing
in this episode but I do quite like the
result in the end and I even did double
with some screens as well as you might
have seen I've got one stone texture
into the base of the station and we've
also got some dungaree texture which
actually works out quite nicely oh I'm
so curious to see it in the time that's
now so maybe in a few minutes but yeah
I'm so happy that you also started
tackling them because like that's also
an important thing about every new stuff
in the game I mean I can have as many
ideas as I want to but it only gets
better if other people also come up with
different ideas and so we just can you
know give each other
even more ideas and also that you said
you have some you know some doubts about
it it's also maybe really interesting to
talk about them to later on and honestly
it's already turning out super well and
super crazy by the way I think you don't
have to mention that you go so much into
details because isn't that's just still
stuff you need to do like going into
math details like would it be a source
of authority wouldn't that's that's a
good point actually I think I kind of
had a bit of a revelation actually a
sudden where I boys cracked terribly
know where I realized that I kind of
feel like we're on different skills in a
sense and in fact I think I'm actually
on a very small scale compared to many
people because a lot of my builds are
usually very small and very much focused
on the tiniest of details whereas a lot
of your builds focus more on on larger
and new ideas and more creative concepts
like working with the screens and make
an entire mind train in one episode
that's that's something that would take
me 10 episodes like I feel like we're on
slightly different skills in that sense
and that works quite well together
actually I think yeah I think especially
in the latest quality Beach episodes
you'll find that a lot of the big stuff
is kind of made by really
at the big projects into quality and
then of the fine-tuning
and bringing the different stuff
together is what I end up doing for
quite a bit and it's very unfortunate
that lady is actually going through some
personal issues at the moment but it's
also very handy to add like something
that I've also noticed is that lady does
more of the middle ground between
bridging what you and I both do I think
it's a very interesting chemistry in
that sense yep definitely it does work
together really well and I think both of
us already recognize this kind of in the
rue des that it doesn't work very well
together and yeah I think lady ed also a
lot of cool stuff to it as you said with
also some really different thoughts but
we don't come up with so that's that
time
yeah I'm really hoping for her that
she's training better but she just needs
to take take all the time to meet so
basically that's it let's just continue
with this reading that sort of of you
know giving each other ideas by having
different skills I mean that's what
collaborations do work for right so
that's coming through actually I want to
bring it back to the build for a little
bit since I wanted to talk about Miami
is that weird name like there's a
pendopo
I don't actually know how to pronounce
it it's an Indonesian name and I've
probably butchered the name but it's the
thing with the red roof which is one of
these small pavilions and that they have
in Indonesia but I think it's also very
interestingly similar to pavilions that
you can find in theme park somewhere
where just a small place where you can
sit or it just fits well in the area to
be honest this is really just something
that I put in there because it works
very well in the be stone with the
coaster itself that was just something
small that I wanted to try yeah by
actually I liked it quite a lot because
it's it's again something new in terms
of you know roof texture and roof color
and a basic shape of the roof because
like that may be also one reason why I
didn't want to tackle the station I was
kind of afraid going into you know
taking the same roof and
again because we you know we just used
it I mean that that's totally yeah just
obvious why we do so and it does nothing
wrong with it but in a way I just didn't
you know I just didn't have to be the
best idea to continue with it and I see
you adding this one how else is called
again spend oh-ho I guess it just adds
something new again and I think it just
works out pretty well as this little
kind of viewpoint over there so yes I
would have never come up with this so
that's just perfect now this this
episode was actually kind of an
experiment in in texturing things and
using different textures because you're
totally right about the fact that we're
forced to use most of the same objects
and especially that same darn roof every
single time and it it results in a very
repetitive Park after a while so this
was also a little bit of a practice in
detailing with different textured
objects so we've got like the Front's
with a bunch of weird things that I've
hardly used like the bank of a door and
a different door on the side as well of
course we've got some screen screens in
there as well and a lot of woodwork with
a lot of ropes I have to give a very
important shoutouts here to lone wolf at
shyguys world who's given quantum of
inspiration for this build here's a
style that includes a lot of clutter a
lot of barrels and ropes and logs in all
sorts of positions and it's a very
natural flowing style and it's one
that's not impressive from a composition
kind of standpoint even even if it's
called even if its composition is very
impressive it's a style that I think is
very impressive because it uses
materials in a very in various ways and
in a very natural and interesting way
and that's something that I wanted to
try a little bit more with this station
has a lot of the Rope work and a lot of
the wooden beam work also trying to do
it in a realistic way so ideally things
aren't nailed together and instead they
have to be built using
the notes of the ropes and it gives
interesting use of clothes as well as
well with the leather and the front and
everything it's super cool I just saw a
few minutes ago how you use those little
ropes that I just hang on to this little
island thing as kind of those assembling
parts for those colors in a way and this
just works so well I also used to do it
in my pirate area and it's just so cool
how you can just put it into those
wooden roundish wooden pillars and to
kind of combine them as if they were you
know stroke together with the rope
that's pretty cool how this works out
mm-hmm and it's something that I guess
pneumatically something important
because it's it's not exactly the sort
of theme where you'd want to have nails
and why you'd want to have modern
building styles that said another way in
which I try to make this building very
distinguished from the other buildings
in the park despite using the same roof
texture and being forced to use the
general same shapes is I've added all
these spires on top of it and this is a
bit of a weird story I'm a spire man
okay that's tempered you hear me there's
a new spider-man movie in oh my god
fireman's fireman doesn't ever aspire
can so yeah I'm a liar I am at home
coming but basically I like to add all
of these little pointy bits to my roots
especially in mice players or all of the
all of the things that that stick out
and are very vertical and long and
pointed and narrow
they're very nice detailing there's
something that are very victorian-esque
stuff that you'd see around like old
world expositions and Paris and I know
Art Nouveau buildings and stuff and it's
something that I kind of just went into
these Polynesian buildings I know it's
it's it's almost like a sort of cultural
appropriation it's it's the type of
Polynesian building that you might find
in a world exposition in Victorian times
but it's something that I felt was
touched at least distinguish it from
other buildings and to be honest I I
can't stop myself from enemy's pointy
bits you'll find them around all of my
buildings yeah I think you're really a
kind of Victorian style ever right I
guess because like in most of your bills
you just have influences of it which is
pretty cool
and honestly aren't we just in kind of
an expo for like because we on this
theme park so that might just make sense
so we can just mix it in and it just
totally makes sense because it you know
it isn't the case that we used like
native buildings but at least this I I
mean in the end this is a themed product
so yeah and yeah it feels a little bit a
little insensitive though I just have to
add and while we were talking about the
ropes as kind of goes those pieces to
assemble stuff it does also make sense
in terms of where this Park would be
because like you know the humidity and
the heat over there is quite heavy and
so in those times and with those you
know resources people have over there
using old screws and that might not be
the best idea because like they will
definitely struggle from their
conditions outside so it might be even a
better idea to use ropes and stuff to
keep your building together instead of
using iron work which will suffer from
the environment influences mm-hmm so I
think that might be also a nice thought
it's actually an interesting take and
just kind of realize that I'm not
entirely sure what the rules and
regulations are in terms of that for
theme parks like our Disney buildings
that look like they're held together by
ropes actually held together by ropes
because I have them I have a strong
suspicion that they would actually have
some kind of internal knee or they
should have grabbed you sure they have
yeah like it's it looks a bit much punch
but it never religious and I'm pretty
sure like I mean like in those areas
like where Disney parks are I'm pretty
sure and with those you know like
security levels they have to stand - I
think they try just do it with ropes but
maybe I'm wrong I think we will have
some really clever people in the
comments that might tell us a little bit
more into I
I even have an idea who could be the
person to do so no I am suspicious as
well yeah it's a kind of stuff that you
weren't really fine too easily in books
or documentaries but yes too niche and
weird is like and weird sub niche
interest information but I wonder my
suspicion gets even closer to the one I
really wonder about the structural
soundness of the wooden constructions of
Disneyland mmm God and I said that that
then I'm a fireman would be my weirdest
sentence in this anyway
well I did I think it's still what fair
enough yeah that's cool honestly I love
how you did this you know cover for the
brake run I guess that's kind of the
preparing it to the transfer track you
were talking about right so yeah it's
you need that in the corner in climates
like it's it's tropical it's it was a
lot of right now that's not the reason I
can I just wanted to have some kind of
architectural little tidbit button like
next to the station since otherwise
looking at the station the station was
like the only building and it came out
really awkward and lonely and
rectangular so it just kind of adds a
little bit of a point of building
interest next to the station but other
than that it's not actually functional
well it doesn't have to right so even
though people have been complaining that
some of our recent builds are lacking
some functional which I can't deny it is
kind of true I guess but yeah so it
would be nice to actually have the
opportunity to make everything
functional in the game some are isn't so
that's afraid of yeah plus there are
actually break ones that have a roof
over them in real life so it's not too
far of a stretch it's not a nice way to
tie it back together with the stage
oh I love how you how you just use the
copy and paste technique over here of
the roof and just like you know taking
those upper bits of the roof in little
spires to just move them around again to
not make the move entirely again just
very clever like that yeah I needed to
resort to a pretty hefty methods to get
more spire than because I did I really
did feel like there weren't enough
spires on that building yet
oh I see hashtag one more spire okay
that's definitely got to be happening
it's just such a neat neat touch to and
everything I mean it's over the top for
sure and it's it's a it's a bit of a
weird reviving new element ik sort of
thing but I it's a theme park I mean
you've been to Austria I guess you just
have been you know you have got so many
influences now from from those kind of
buildings as well from Austria so that's
a fair I guess oh yeah that's true
actually I went to Salzburg last week
well yep so there was a half the amount
of spires in that I think it's a neat
city isn't it it is really nice have you
been direction yeah I've been there yeah
I mean I've every man lost in there when
I was young but I didn't remember saying
no I've been tagged s two years ago one
year ago no two years ago but yeah all
right I really loved it but what
honestly might be really uncommon for
Austria but it was a really hot place
back then and I also enjoyed shadow but
I just you know there is at least a
little bit of shadow but the city itself
it's you know there's a lot of open
space even though it doesn't seem like
and that was not that easy in this cold
hot conditions but I guess you just had
nice weather as well did you yeah it was
not too hot so it's pretty nice I always
hated it when it's too hot like it does
matter which city I just seen in them
yeah and cities are warmer than their
Yap surrounding so that's the best part
about it but no I wasn't too bad and
there are some narrow streets in there
as well yeah that's right cap so I
really like it I really like the kind of
architecture going on there and I I just
know like this kind of flair that you
can see the Alps and stuff that's cool
oh yeah that's really nice
it's interesting you with a very Baroque
style yeah in fact actually I did the
most pretentious thing today I set in
the garden outside in the Sun reading a
book about Baroque architecture that's
something that happened today and did
you listen to classic me exactly that
shuffle I mean if I will into Mozart at
the same time I'm sure my brain can
handle her and I would I would have gone
mad
that's not even that's that's too much
that's too much for a brain to handle
but it's it was it was actually pretty
nice I didn't even read too much it was
mostly looking at pictures so far there
was good inspiration oh yeah that makes
sense about architecture right so maybe
we should bring this back to Kowalik a
show is one more one more topic that we
actually talked a bit about before the
video that we can probably talk for half
an hour about but there are also kind of
name drops at the beginning of the video
because we've got the new screens and
they're the hip new thing in the game
because it as green means you can add
any texture whatsoever anything that's
on your computer even including whatever
weird things you might have on your
computer you can put anything on a
screen and it's in the game so
essentially you have any texture so
that's how the water was made that's how
the aquarium is made and that's how some
of the building textures so far have
been made but it really has been I mean
you've been mad pioneer on this
technique and I know you've come up with
a lot of ideas and uses for this
technique but I've actually I'm sort of
skeptical about it since this was my
first test and I'm not sure how I feel
about it I'm not sure what your feelings
exactly or only though yeah I think we
just don't need to start from the very
beginning again because we talked
already a tiny little bit about it so I
just try to you know bring it to a
conclusion for the guys out there and to
go on with my thoughts then because I
think you felt already in the last
episode that I started to be a little
bit more skeptical so basically our
problem is that like for both of us that
the textures are as a texture itself are
really flat and either just gloss
and shiny because the screen itself has
a known like standard ish spectacular
map to it so if you do put in a texture
it is not as if it would be if you just
have a normal texture going on which has
a known spectacular map to each and
every fits to it and my hand out for a
second but it's it's specular map and
yeah inspector I mean they are
spectacular but yeah here can we right
yeah yeah you are absolutely right but
yeah they don't have a spectacular
specular map yeah where anyways so I
think the usage of those and the
possibilities we get our tremendous
they're really amazing but that said I
also talked about this with those little
details I added to the slides over there
we also recognize that it doesn't work
that well in the end because you never
ever would get the same writing to the
same picture as if it was in game before
so the would never would be looking like
the would in game because it has a
different specular map to it and yeah so
I think I do really see your point
that said using it for different kind of
ideas it's still one of the best
additions to the game ever so I am
working at the moment and something else
which doesn't even need to have those
specular Maps so I think in terms of how
you can use them they really are a game
changer but a few things already dropped
a little bit because of the missing
specular map mm-hmm so that's all my
thoughts yeah I still think they're
amazing as well but I'm actually on the
fence as to whether I actually think
that they're one of the best additions
to the game it's something that I
noticed when I looked at the stone for
the first time because that stone takes
you that you see on the station is one
of the first stitches that I tried is
yeah exactly because of the the map the
reflection doesn't quite work the same
way as the in-game textures where it
actually works locally like if you have
bricks they actually do look different
at 9 a.m. than they do at I think 1:30
or something you're kidding at the
shadows and the highlights actually do
line up depending on the lighting that's
something that you cannot get with the
imported textures so for me they they
still kind of stick out hence why I sort
of blended the textures and I sort of
saw this as an experiment to see how you
can blend the texture in using all of
that foliage and the rook work and the
wood but that said you are right that I
think it's it's it's a good thing for
other creative ideas like getting actual
video screens into the U game getting
stuff done I have seen is getting the
height requirements and explanation sign
yeah really hearing times and stuff like
that outside of your rides building
again is of course okay I might also
though those kind of photo pre you know
those those screens so you can see of
action photo of the right in the pirate
area so you can when you walk outside
the exit of the right you just can see
the photo taking of you in the right
with actual photos of the game that
works out for pre-need yep yeah I
totally agree I think there's none
really really interesting ways to work
with it but as a texture thing I'm very
much in the fence and that's why I feel
it might not be as as game-changing as
it as it was once thought it would be
chance it's something that yes it's
changing allows you to add anything
anything into the game but it also feels
a little bit and it's basically - yeah
yeah that was basically because I I just
saw at the beginning it's still a
mistake it still sucks because there was
also something going on in the forum
already that there is kind of a back
with the lighting to it and I was hoping
that it fixed but now as it is fixed a
tiny little bit and yeah I still see the
problem that you mentioned as well so I
don't have anything else to say about it
so I have to ask one more question if
you did know about the barrel planter oh
yeah I mean I actually place the barrel
planter in pendopo
all right so as kind of the way to make
people not run into the Phyllis yeah
okay
did you know about that before like I
actually do okay so because I I was
shocked when and so many people didn't
know about that because I also didn't
know about that and this weird guy
called absolute TV he was like oh well
wasn't it kind of a thing that is very
well known and I was like no actually
before all the viewers are like what is
happening basically the barrel planter
is the one object in the game that
people walk around so if you place it on
the path people walk around it but even
if you sink it into the pond
people still walk around that part of
the park so you can actually use it to
place walls and objects on a park and
have people walk around it realistically
instead of going through it yeah that's
basically what happened not just madness
it's so cool you can use it for so many
different of places and ideas and it's
yeah yeah we have just known it before
I'll actually I'll link that video in
the description because it's something
that needs to be seen and anybody
doesn't know it yet
here's your there's no chance to do some
more revolutionary spoken again I hope
you've known otherwise this is this is
such a terrible moment the things that
I'm going on in the past if I knew
somebody yeah if it works out pretend oh
brother I was actually my first test
trying it so yeah there's no reason for
people to go into it though so it's it's
useless but maybe maybe we can put an
attraction point in there something like
yeah that's I think I still want to have
it I mean it's totally totally not how
the game should work but I totally want
to have kind of an option to place and a
hidden piece somewhere to make people go
there I don't know it just you know as a
for example like the entertainment point
just as a little sticky thing you can
put onto the pathway and people would go
there just to make people go there
because they were to realistically go
there to have like the view I don't know
if that makes sense but I just want to
have it or maybe just a slight AOH in
that some people do go into the random
spots we don't really fight anything
dunno oh yeah some people are like that
for some reason I mean I am but listen I
cannot speak with too many people here
but yeah I think that's that's a good
way to run them this episode because
I've long run out of time lapse
actually we've gone on for a long time
oh so do you have still some stuff
quarter you to the Med extent but anyway
yeah I've got in some sex I don't know
what we're gonna do in the next episode
or what's going to happen I'm sorry
we're on a very inconsistent schedule
and way of actually doing the work
there's just too many issues to deal
with at the moment we've come on it but
it's still going strong and when I
finished this park although I also have
to add we do kind of feel like it's
nearing the end sometime soon like it's
not just yet happy-go-lucky building
we're even filling up the park map
pretty pretty neatly over here
yeah it's into the wrapping up stages
but yeah I don't think we should head to
anything about how many episodes left
well but I'm definitely not gonna put in
another dive coaster or something yeah
we would have to dodge go since I'm into
it I'm gonna mm hypercoaster Hey yes
welcome some space well now yeah well
sort that out anyway thank you guys for
watching thank you really for being here
yeah what's a pleasure and we'll see you
guys in the next episode whatever it may
be
bye my bike